for the last seven years twitch streamer
and content creator amranth has been
stuck in an abusive relationship with
her husband he has had partial control
over her finances and over the years has
forced her to make content and during
the live stream phone call where this
was all revealed on he verbally abused
amranth to tears and even threatened to
harm her dogs this is a very dark
situation so we will do our best to
break down what we know
before we start I'd like to issue a
Content warning for this video since we
will be discussing domestic abuse among
other things if you or someone you know
is facing domestic violence we have put
links in the description to support
hotlines so over the weekend amaranth
was streaming OverWatch 2 with several
other content creators when she stepped
away to take a phone call amaranth
looked visibly anxious and said it was a
call from her assistant regarding a
situation that they had to handle for
the next hour and a half amaranth was
just off screen speaking to someone on
the phone while her mic was muted
amaranth came back and unmuted herself
and what we heard was a man on the other
end of the call berating her
what
exactly because I'm gonna let you say
what you think you heard and then I'm
gonna say what I thought
that
you're mine because I'm locking her up
here what are you saying from what we
can tell it seems like the conversation
started a bit earlier in the day and
might have stemmed from a conversation
about wanting her to stream for long
hours or even participate in a threesome
but specifically during the call
amaranth's husband was screaming at her
for not listening and insinuating that
he was crazy but amaranth was more
preoccupied with the fact that her
husband said that he was going to hurt
her dogs
why did you say you were gonna kill my
dogs
okay I can leave that like you know what
actually I don't think I shouldn't leave
the house because my dogs are here
we'll take the dogs late
her husband then continued to scream at
belittle and Gaslight amaranth until she
was in tears he later claimed that
amaranth and her assistant attempted to
swat him but she said she only called
the police because he was getting
physical with her while trying to take
away her phones but directly after that
her husband admitted to lying and
bending the truth in order to tear down
her Empire you're literally just lying
to my Twitter
once the phone call ended amaranth began
to talk directly to her stream while
continuing to deal with the situation
that's when we all learned a lot more to
start we all learned that the man on the
other line was in fact her husband not
something that was public information
prior to this everyone was under the
assumption that amaranth was single and
despite it being entirely reasonable
amaranth didn't actually want to keep
her relationship a secret it was only
because her husband thought it would
harm the business but we'll touch on
that a bit later so if you're wondering
why her husband was being so open during
this call is because he didn't realize
that he was on stream once he did his
tone changed pretty quickly and
unfortunately the abuse that we all
witnessed was not just the beginning for
amaranth amaranth claimed that her
husband would take her off stream for
hours at a time just to scream at her
she pleaded for him to seek therapy but
to no avail when it came to the actual
business side of things to say that her
husband was controlling would be an
understatement her husband constantly
criticized her for not doing more in
terms of content numbers always moving
the goal posts of what he expected from
her she even showed that he threatened
to sell her horses if she didn't stream
more or hit us certain viewer count to
make matters worse he also had access to
all her bank accounts social medias and
all the two-factor authentications even
went back to his phone which was quote
by his design in a heartbreaking moment
amaranth actually said that they used to
get along that was until everything
became about money for him he wanted
every aspect of her life to revolve
around making content and would become
enraged whenever she did anything off
stream for example her addition to
twitch's hot tub meta was mostly due to
him pushing for it and on top of that he
forced her to stream long hours not
letting her sleep and despite how
lucrative her content has been all his
regulations made her feel like she was
quote Living in a fancy prison it even
got to the point where he was
threatening to blow all her money on
crypto and other random things if she
didn't follow every one of his demands
for the clothes huh deleting social
media in one minute buying options at
expiring blasting the cash about to shut
down the bank account to your bank
account too on top of trying to control
every aspect of her life amaranth also
showed what would happen if she ever
tried to displease him you know what you
are I would like my dork but he broke
that too
[Music]
best advice I can give during my divorce
my grandma gave this too shall pass hold
on for me
and so I ran in here to call the cops
and he literally kicked the door in and
broke like this doesn't even have a
hinge anymore as disheartening as this
entire stream was its ending was even
more abrupt and concerning
what are you talking about
why would you ask if I'm taking my
her door opened a cracked and her
assistant asked if amaranth had been
taking her medication amaranth looked
confused and then the stream cut out all
we know is that amaranth was in fact
safe after the stream ended many content
creators reached out directly or over
social media to offer support with some
even doing Wellness checks to make sure
amaranth was safe of course even more
people took to Twitter to condemn the
actions of amaranth's husband and even
highlight the seriousness of domestic
abuse unfortunately as with all drama
there was plenty of disgusting takes
online but there is one common bad faith
argument I wanted to try and help dispel
as I said before if keeping her
relationship private was something that
she wanted to do that was completely her
right full stop she is not lying to
anybody nor is she tricking her audience
or customers creators deserve the
Privacy that they want and your
connection to them does not go past
whatever type of entertainment they're
providing you on top of that just
because you don't like a content creator
doesn't mean that they deserve any form
of abuse or claims that they're lying
about the abuse for views some people
even attempted to criticize amaranth for
giving so much control over to her
husband I'd explain how stupid this
argument is but I think Linus already
put it best if your victim blaming
amranth for giving her spouse access to
her accounts then I guess I'm also dumb
for being in business with my wife you
don't marry someone unless you trust
them and it's not a sin to be open and
vulnerable with a partner and thankfully
it wasn't just Linus other larger voices
in the community also offered their
support he believes that
it's calling him crazy and she might not
be calling him crazy but I as well as
everyone else who has seen these clips
is this man is unhinged he is crazy this
man is nuts now yesterday amaranth was
supposed to go live but moments before
that she tweeted that someone had called
the cops eventually she did end up going
live and gave everybody an update on her
situation amaranth confirmed that her
husband truly did control everything
from what she was allowed to wear to
what she was allowed to do as feel like
I have to turn down invites to [__] camp
and stuff now or like the girls trip
because it's not
good
not good use of time
couldn't be home getting more
conversions and money
I can actually feel like I can have
friends again most importantly amaranth
has regained access to all of her
accounts and her husband is out of the
house seeking help on top of that
amaranth is also seeking help both
legally and for the emotional trauma she
also gave us some information regarding
some of her now former employees and
whether or not they were using the
situation for cloud or even sat on
information that could have helped her I
don't believe that we've ever seen abuse
like this live on Twitch before at least
not from a high profile Creator like
this but it's important to know that
situations like this do happen and sex
workers are even more susceptible to
this type of controlling behavior for
that reason we also have links in the
description that can provide help for
sex workers as of right now that's all
we know about the situation if anything
else develops we'll do what we can to
keep you all informed
foreign